what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to another code review
yeah this series is still alive so
basically for those of you who have not
heard of this series i'll have like the
last episode linked up there there's
like a whole playlist and everything
this is basically just me taking a look
at the code that i received from the
community from you guys
and this can be absolutely anything uh
in fact i've kind of like i've been
thinking about this series and i think
that rather than me trying to critically
you know uh judge your code as if i'm
like you know
somehow authorized to do that or
whatever i'm not your academic professor
right um this would be more of like a
little fun series you know
fun trying to transpire fun in my life
and in yours as well
where basically i would just look at
interesting code from the community
give my thoughts you know i might give
some suggestions i might just
you know speak my mind but it is not
supposed to be like a you know
hand in your homework and i will churno
will mark you and then probably
discourage you from ever programming
again which can be the case so yeah so
that that's kind of long story short of
what this series is today we have
alexander alexander valenov
volnov i don't know hi y'all my name is
alexander i'm 26.
good start i'm also 26. privet is
receive also an excellent start
first of all thank you for your content
in particular the game engine series
you've developed my
3d game engine for a long time as a
hobby but about it five years ago
um that's understandable game engines
are very difficult to make but recently
i discovered your channel and your
videos gave me some new ideas inspired
me to continuous development cool i
wanted to share a demo
that implements a simple particle
rendering technique in c
plus an opengl i came up with it while i
was developing my engine and later
extracted it into a separate demo
the demo also has some music and it fits
in in just a single 4k
executable cool so it's like literally
like a demo like a demo scene style demo
that's really cool
because i have not looked at anything
close to this um and that's actually one
of the reasons why i selected this
here is a link to the repository all
right let's take a look at these
particles um i haven't taken a look at
this really i mean i've skimmed through
it to make sure that it's
going to be decent content for you guys
but i haven't really uh examined it yet
so this is what it looks like i guess um
it's a demo
gpu particle system technique written in
simple slots and open gel 3
also simple procedural music inside cool
so i guess the music gets created by the
actual software
um there's a pre-built 4k binary that i
might open that
um before you do so see control section
below blah blah blah with cmake demo
vlogs a demo
um oh and good some interesting controls
so i might save these controls
how it works that's cool seeing a little
how it works section so i don't have to
explain
that to you guys i guess unlike most
existing methods my technique doesn't do
any step-by-step
simulation instead particle trajectory
size
color and other parameters are defined
as functions of time
yeah so that's pretty common to see like
on cheddar toy um for those of you who
don't know by the way that's probably a
good kind of thing if you guys are
interested in stuff like this if the
stuff that i'm about to show today
interests you you should definitely
check take a look at shader toy shader
toy is a website
um it sounds like they're sponsoring
this video shady toy is a website um
that basically just has people writing
various shaders
that do things and because there's no
real state like you can write to
textures and
you know do stuff like that but there's
no real state like this isn't like a an
application or a program
it's kind of all generated you know
using this kind of shader text and
essentially it's a fragment shader
running like on a quad so because of
that
um you know a lot of it is like a
function of time or a function of like
the mouse
you know uh location stuff like that so
this is cool it's kind of similar
and i always love looking at this stuff
to be honest speaking
of sponsors though however this video is
sponsored by skillshare so for those of
you who don't know skillshare is an
amazing online learning community where
millions of creative and curious people
from all around the world can come
together
into one place to learn some new skills
through their amazing
selection of high quality classes
whether you're trying to learn a new
skill or polish up an existing skill
skill share
is the perfect place for you they have
classes on literally everything if
you're interested in photography
videography
marketing video editing in fact there's
a fantastic course that i've just been
watching today
by mkbhd that just teaches you all about
youtube because
clearly i have no idea what i'm doing i
also really like a lot of their
illustration classes and the best thing
about these classes is that they're so
concise and high quality and to the
point
they're not going to be these like hour
long courses that you have to do they're
extremely easy to consume
if you don't have much time available i
mean take a look at this mkbhd course as
an example
look at those times these classes are
perfect for you if you're busy and i
mean
who isn't coming in at just under 10 a
month for an annual subscription it's
absolutely fantastic value
but skillshare is also giving the first
1000 people who click the link in the
description below
a free trial of skillshare premium so
that you can check it out for yourselves
and see what's on their platform huge
thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
and let's take a look at some particles
okay so here we have the cloned
repository now it is uh it does build
using cmake so i'm just going to go
ahead and quickly run
cmg making a little build directory as
per usual
to get some of these project files
generated for visual studio great so he
did mention there was a i guess in bin
yeah there is this kind of four kilobyte
executable 3.62 kilobytes that's pretty
impressive
um yeah demos are always really cool to
look at but let's
let's just go ahead and build it
ourselves so that we can examine the
code as well okay so let's expand this
up
uh source files okay demo main i guess
is
probably a good place to start let's
just build it and run it and see what
we're looking at
i've got to make sure to set that as the
startup project
it's got some music
look at that particles i'm going to
enjoy the full experience
so okay so controls he mentioned let me
just bring them up because they
are useful okay so one to nine is number
of particles
can't tell if that's like more particles
or less particles because these look
like they're so wide and condensed
but these look like they're just more
spread out
okay that's cool shift and control is
running speed okay i see you can slow it
down and you can speed it up
left and right arrows changes the time
direction p is to pause and resume
and eyes to restart
or it just clears everything until i do
that okay cool
so that's the particle system let's take
a look at how it's built
okay so the first thing that i want to
point out quickly as i look through this
code for
the first time is this is a demo right i
mean this is clearly a demo it's like a
four kilobyte demo
it's supposed to be as short and to the
point as possible this is not some game
engine that's going to
just be written in a super easy to
understand way probably or
using all the libraries this is supposed
to be really simple and you can actually
see the way that it starts up here as
well
we're just using the win32 api to create
a window linking glow
or sdl would be would massively increase
the binary size
and that's not something that we need
for a demo platform apis like windows
clearly capable
of providing us with a window so why not
just do that so my point is that this is
not good code to
to kind of read i guess to learn from if
you're interested in making like
actual applications or games because
it's a demo
by the way link to this code will be in
the description every single one of
these episodes does have the link in the
description
so you can just unless it was like sent
to me in a zip file or something this is
on github so the link will be in the
description below if you want to check
it out of course
and actually one thing i um forgot to
mention was that
um i noticed this at the bottom as well
so there's a webgl version there's also
an android version which is more
advanced
which is really cool so you can check
this out on android if you want okay so
step one
is let's see we created we created gl
window i guess and this is just all
pretty much 132 api code to create an
opengl window i guess we load
various opengl functions which of course
are all kind of done using wgl
get proc address because it's trying to
be as small of a binary as possible
we're not trying to link any libraries i
guess this doesn't use any libraries at
all
i'm sure if we went into like properties
and we take we took a look at the linker
um the only stuff that it links is all
of this stuff that that's
all available for you with windows it
all ships with windows
i also assume there aren't too many kind
of advanced um opengl functions i would
imagine like if i was writing this demo
i'd probably try and keep it i mean he
said open gel 3 i think but
i would try and keep it as low as
possible i assume he's going to need
shaders to actually you know
create the particles and stuff um but
you know
you wouldn't you wouldn't try and use
all the latest features because you
don't need them it's a demo
um then we instantiate this demo class
we're on the constructor
which creates a whole bunch of stuff
cool all right so screen width and
height
sure guesses the metric so it's actually
getting the physical like width and
height of the
display you're running on particle
effect description i guess
um we have a bunch of cons char pointers
so these are actually stored in the
binary
so if we if we take a look at let's see
build i guess debug there's the
executable i'm going to open in hxd
which is my favorite
uh hex kind of binary editor i guess um
and then let's make this a little bit
wider um
scroll down okay so you can see that
like the shader code let me just kind of
make this a little bit
maybe easier to see um the shader code
is literally just stored statically in
the binary itself now because the
the final output binary was 4k
um i'm sure he's probably using some
techniques to compress that because text
text of course compresses extremely well
right these are also gel draw regional
enabled those are probably all the names
of the functions he's retrieving
um using that kind of wgl uh get you
know whatever it was
here it is wgl get proc address gl and
then he's concatenating
the name of the function he wants so
that kind of it's a macro it expands and
it
it's in the binary now but anyway as i
was saying because the text compresses
extremely well he's probably further
compressed that so i
imagine if we opened up the 4k um and
i'm not like some kind of demo expert by
the way i don't think i've ever made a
demo in my life
um at least not intentionally uh
yeah like this is the entire 4k file
right
i mean there's no text here so i imagine
it's probably like compressed or
magic some way i don't know but that's
basically where all of that code will
end up so these are all kind of
just const chart pointers they don't
need to be strings or anything like that
would only like heap allocate anything
um or try and do that we can just kind
of store them in the static memory
of our application which is what's going
on there okay
i've i have lost everything as usual so
let's see
demo that's that's where we were we were
instantiating the demo and running
through the constructor
okay so we have all of these kind of
construct pointers to uh
shaders to shaded code obviously these
aren't complete cheddar codes they're
just
individual functions i guess which is
interesting then we do effect dot 2
shader which uh sprint f's
the vertex shader code with the shader
template and then the color phone okay
all of these get like
concatenated um let's take a look at
this uh well not concatenated actually
this
is the format and then this is these are
like all the
like i guess percentage sign s
um kind of strings that get get put in
there so this is really the key
um so let's i don't know where this can
where this lives
vertex shader code let's just quickly i
don't know i'll just search for it
um
yeah where does that it get set oh hang
on vertex trader template oh sorry
that's the target
that's the format my bad so this is the
buffer in which it's going to
um you know put the resulting string
into
this is the template and this is i guess
the actual
um the format right so as if you were
doing printf and then you'd have your
actual format string and then these are
like all the arguments for the format
string so this is the actual shader
okay and then yeah so you can see like
there's like get position
or like get emitter position get size
get color and then they just have
percentage sign
s right percent s which just means like
take in the appropriate argument
it's a little bit dodgy right because
obviously the order of these matters so
much if you just mess them up then your
color function will be your size
function and vice versa
so it's a little bit dogecoin but um
you know it's a demo that's great you
know that that's the best excuse write a
demo and then be like no i had to do it
this way man it keeps the binary size
smaller
best um okay so yeah version 130 pretty
old
um define particle ideas gel vertex id
so we're probably
what are we how are we actually
rendering this maybe we'll start with
there
um so we do demo step which what does
that do
right okay so we're just doing some i
guess this is what's
query performance counter is a 132 api
function that will actually
retrieve like the current time for you
um
and this kind of sets it up as well so
this is like the current cpu time so
this is what we're using for time
um it's like 128 bit
uh number which is why quad part gets
the kind of 32 bit
out of it so it's a long long now maybe
it's even a 64 bit
um because it is a long long right how
big is a large
integer these days anyway whatever um
get uh
async key state um i so that's
us just basically saying if the key is
pressed sending resetting time to zero
which is
what's supposed to reset the particle
simulation um
rates okay okay right one plus i
so this is actually how many particles
there are yeah so the lower number the
less particles
right so this is two thousand particles
i assume if we press the one key
and then if we press like the three key
it'll be ten thousand particles right
so that's just making sure that we do uh
that we retrieve the current
key and then use it to actually uh
write okay and if it's not that key we
continue so we basically run this 10
times to get the async key set of all of
our
um well not ten times nine times um to
get all the
all of the uh key states of the one
through nine
number keys if it's not pressed we just
skip if it is pressed um
then we'll do all of this and we'll
break right this sets a bunch of
uniforms and just figures out how many
particles we actually want
cool delta time um shifting control just
increases speed or decreases speed we
know that left
right set speed to be negative right so
um if speed is greater than the zeros
it's just that's reversing time i guess
which is what runs it backwards
uh pause okay yeah anyway this stuff is
pretty straightforward render frame this
is what i want so
we clear the color buffer we load
identity translate rotate
um uniform one f time uh
yeah so we set the time into the shader
as a uniform and then gel draw arrays
gel points zero
and this is the count okay so we're
drawing everything as points
that's cool um i think actually as i was
skimming this
he did mention that um
this method is the only way in order to
simulate particles on gpu that can be
implemented in unextended opengl
es 2.0 for example it works with mali
400 gpu which is like a
an android gpu which has no support for
vertex textures
pbo like pixel buffer objects transform
feedback or compute shaders yeah so
we're dealing with like a pretty old
kind of thing
but you know that's not necessarily a
bad thing as i mentioned for a demo
because i'm sure that this is going to
be less verbose than like having to
compile compute shaders and stuff like
that
um which is going to be pretty good and
it seems to perform pretty well
um okay so we're drawing a raise so what
is the array that we're drawing so we're
probably creating it somewhere here um
[Music]
time rate okay these are all uniform
locations oh here we go gen buffers
array buffer
so we're generating an array buffer it's
four
bytes large
and no data is being set into there i
don't think we do actually need data if
we're going to
emit things um and then we enable point
spread okay so point spread and program
points right this is a blast from the
past
so this is basically a way for you to be
like i'm rendering
points but i want to give them like a
size and
program point size means that you can
set that size from within the shader so
if we were to take a look at the shader
which we will
in a minute um he's probably setting the
size of the particles
and so we're basically just rendering
these kind of sprites
and that's what the particles actually
are and this is the amount that we're
rendering so it's going to be
the minimum of time and lifetime times
the rate
that's just how many points we draw and
obviously the shader works out where
they're supposed to be
you know how big they are what the color
currently is and all of that
all of that is figured out from the one
uniform that is just the time so we fit
in this value into the shader
it runs all of the functions all of the
equations and then we then have a
resulting
you know position on the screen a
resulting
time sorry a resulting color a resulting
size all of that kind of stuff
just based off of this one variable that
we run through all of those algorithms
so that's how all of this is working
um and again you know we're rendering a
lot of these so
here's a good example so was that even
supposed to be gel
size i'll be nice gel size i count
equals that and then i'll just print out
i'll be in the spirit of um
c or whatever and we'll just do what is
this unsigned long long or something
uh it's in it wow that's that's easy
um uh we'll just do count here
so this is this is the amount of
particles that we're rendering
printf is undefined ah do i have to use
like
oh we don't have a console do we oh
that's annoying
no
okay i'm going to destroy his binary by
just including standard io.h
i don't think we do we actually yeah we
did create a console
right so we've got this is how many
particles we have right so it's growing
because we're
spawning more and more particles did
that just pause
um we're spawning more and more
particles obviously the life they're not
dying but at
some point i think this is going to
stabilize let's maybe make this a bit
smaller except now we can't resize it
great
um okay so 50 000 right and at that
point i guess we just
those old ones are dying and stuff but
if i change
this now we have 8 000 if i change that
now we have
what is that a million um escape closes
and unfortunately i was trying to
release the mouse but um anyway you get
the point right so
this is how many points we're telling
opengl to draw and then each one of
those points is going to go through the
vertex shader
and then eventually the fragment shadow
right so let's take a look at that
shader quickly
um let's see on the music stuff we
haven't even taken this there's so much
stuff to take a look at this these are
always going to be kind of long these
videos i think let me know what you guys
think of this format at least because
i'm just having fun looking at this to
be honest
um and it's i just think it's a pretty
cool project that obviously you guys can
check out for yourselves
um using the link below so
uh the shader i think isn't shaded.h
yeah okay so this is the shader we've
got all the uniforms here the viewport
size
um uh let's see just random
random number generation functions um
rotation i guess getting a rotation
matrix back from like
some euler angles um get colors i
mentioned
is a product of that so i guess we can
take a look at one of those shaders as
an example
so the color function for example right
so first of all what does that take in
um let's go to shadow.h it takes in just
time right so we have a t
variable for like all of these functions
right um
[Music]
and then we're basically i guess
generating a random number
um for the main color which is obviously
going to be at some point oh we have
birth time as well
so birth time is that just something to
get set
yeah birth time is something that we
create here and i guess yeah get color
and get time takes them in
and birth time i guess is going to be
based on time
and lifetime where does lifetime come
from
lifetime is a uniform that we pass in
okay cool so we do keep track of some
things i guess
um like there's more than just time that
goes into this there's like i guess
lifetime being
just the lifetime um the age of like the
particle
uh or rather should it be the
total right okay
um the total lifetime i guess
lifetime let's take
a look so lifetime location and we set
that
yeah so we set that based on the number
that we press and also at the beginning
it's set to something um it sets just
five
okay um we have start color which is
just a function
based on the birth time by the way these
random number generators just so that
you guys are aware
this is not like calling a random number
generator in like c plus plus
this is all very deterministic so if we
look at
um the actual function the generated
random number
you can see what it basically does so it
is based off of a seed that you pass
in right and then it will give you like
a number that you know mathematically
will be quite different from the seed
that you obviously pass in
but if you're passing the same seed
you're going to get the exact same
number again
right everything has to be deterministic
we don't want particles flashing around
the screen or doing something weird like
that
right everything needs to be recreated
based off of a single value and that
single value in this case is that time
variable
so that eventually comes into this so if
we go back to like shader.h
or sorry this was in demo.cpp so this is
all based off of birth time it's a
random value
but it is also determined by birth time
if i pass in the same birth time and
this is just the y
value of the seed if i pass in the same
birth time i'm going to get the same
random number out right so it's not
really random it's um
just i guess different very different
than what you pass in
originally and that's a lot of what like
shader
random numbers are so if you see like
random numbers being used in shaders
most likely unless they're being passed
in like by some uniform or whatever
usually they're deterministic because
just like if you wanted
you know your shadow to kind of be you
know
smoothed out and scattered somewhat
randomly you wouldn't actually want it
to be random because
then it would change every frame and
that would be like weird it'd be
flickering
so what you actually want is a way to
make it seem random but also to be
stable
and predictable right and that's what
these functions are basically doing
um and then we just return a mix of like
a whole bunch of different colors based
on a factor and
you know whatever i mean this is the
kind of stuff that you could probably
sit down and play with for hours just
tweaking these algorithms i love stuff
like this honestly
but i don't think there's much point in
me trying to walk you through this code
it's all
very like straightforward it's all just
maths right so you could definitely um
if you're interested take a look at this
stuff
and maybe even learn some stuff and try
it out in your own
code as well or on shaded toy as i
mentioned okay so that's all the kind of
rendering stuff so
the point is we just render all these
points and i'm assuming there's
something in the vertex
shader that actually yeah so we set the
point
size to be a particular value here
that's like the size of that sprite
and then we set the position to be
somewhere on the screen
and so we're actually so we are actually
rendering geometry kind of
right this isn't like running on a quad
kind of like you might do if you were
running this through a compute shader or
just in a fragment shader you can see
that this is all kind of
happening on the vertex shader and then
on the fragment shader all we're really
doing
um is getting that i guess coordinate
and then just drawing like
the color right but the color is also
based off of the factor because i assume
we want it to kind of
fade out toward towards the edges
because this is the vector color meaning
um it's also going to be affecting the
alpha
right so you'll probably get that fade
fade off and that's why you get the
blending and stuff i'm assuming he has
blending enabled
um otherwise nothing would work um where
would that be
uh blend i'll just search for blend jill
enabled your blend
right so if we didn't do this it would
look very
it would look very different yeah so
this is actually a really good way
to see what's happening if you're a
little bit confused you're looking at
this and you're
like a little bit confused i'll just
pause it by holding the title bar
if you're looking at this and you're a
little bit confused as to what's going
on this is how it's being rendered right
it's
very very obvious now um it's just
the music's still going but whatever
must be running on a different thread
um or something that's annoying that i
did that but whatever anyway you can see
kind of what's going on here
um it's just kind of drawing at that
point which i had the mouse cursor but
you can kind of see where it's drawing
hopefully new particles and then if i
change these
um so this is me pressing like the nine
key now you can see just how many
points there actually are but
furthermore you can see what the sprites
kind of look like right and because they
don't have blending they don't
really fade out um they just kind of
remain as uh
squares and then you have that kind of
black border but the color
still fades out it kind of gets darker
and darker towards black in like a
circle kind of radius
and that's why um you know the very
corners are black
and you get this kind of nice radial
pattern i guess
um and obviously if we were to enable
blending back
everything would um fade out very
smoothly
and then the kind of blending effect
because that's the other thing right
let's take a look at this um you know
this isn't your typical
blend function right it's not source
alpha one minus source alpha it's source
alpha one
right so you get that kind of additive
effect which is why it's so bright
right because when stuff blends it kind
of gets added um
actually uh
blend funk i don't think the blend
equation is being set anywhere
but that's kind of what you end up with
if you're confused how opengl blend
functions and stuff like that work
i actually have an opengl video up there
with like a powerpoint presentation and
everything
going over some of the common blend
functions and what they do so
check that out if you want some more
information all right and last but not
least let's take a look at how the music
works
um now i'm not an audio programmer um
even though i love audio
um so let's take a look at this yeah so
it is running on a different thread
we have a music synth thread wave
wav header okay cool so i guess this
creates some kind of wav
file or something um because it's got
like a header here with a particular
sample rate
44.1 k pretty standard um
and then yeah we just have some
mathematical functions which at some
point i guess get fed into some kind of
synthesizer
um and that's what actually creates this
sound so guitar note
we have some like certain amplitudes i
guess that create actual
you know notes and actual music and then
we pass in
like i guess a frequency so what
tone what pitch we want the note to be
um
and then what does that actually do so
i guess it adds it to like some kind of
yeah destination buffer
right and then we eventually so this is
the temp
buffer destination and then we
eventually i guess we play that so
guitar was like a call from destination
vibraphone notes cool all these
different notes going on that's all
going into music synth
um which is going to the thread function
right um
that's calling so that's the okay
whatever it goes into this destination i
guess
and then how do we actually play the
music though where's that being fed into
something ah here we go so this actually
took me a little bit of
um time to find but basically music init
right this this spins off another thread
which is this
music synth function over here that's
running that probably takes a little bit
of time to run right because it's
actually going through and generating
all this stuff
um i don't know how long exactly it
takes but it's doing its thing on a
different thread
meanwhile though we create all this
stuff store it in this kind of buffer
that we uh you know have inside this
music init function
and then we play this right so we're
passing this buffer to snd play sound
which is like a win32
sound player right and then it's just
playing the buffer and i guess that
buffer obviously contains like the
header for like a wav file and
everything
so this is if we it's really as if we
like just um you know read a wav
file from disk and then just passed it
into this function
right except we've generated it all
ourselves including like the header
information and stuff
and then obviously created the actual
music using code which is really cool so
if you're interested in some audio
programming
this might be a little rough but jump in
and take a look at this kind of stuff
because uh yeah it's really cool how
we're able to generate music and this
isn't just some stupid sound it's
actually like a little bit of a song
which i think is pretty cool all right i
think that's pretty much
it so we've covered like the music we've
covered the
rendering um yeah i think it
makes sense overall this was a pretty
cool project to look at we haven't
really looked at utilities but this is
like stuff like create windows and
whatever yeah i love looking at demos i
love looking at cool little projects
like this let me know what you guys
thought if you enjoyed this don't forget
to hit the like button below as well and
check out the project for yourselves if
you want to
if you want to send in some code or a
project for me to look at there'll be an
email address in the description below
that you can send your code to channel
review
gmail.com don't forget to check out
skillshare by using the link in
description below
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you